chips chips
here we go try to catch this mini in
your
those mouth didn't go in the eye
yeah bruce was like my eye
did we hit a spaceship yeah it's a car
in classic courier craft
probably trying to deliver a message i
got to get to the bottom what kind of
message that's just kind of funny right
when you're grandmaster
and they say i have to get a box and
clear it out
bring it back
also
[Laughter]
welcome back to new rockstars she-hulk
episode 1 introduces us to bruce
banner's cousin jennifer walters who
takes on bruce's blood after a car
accident
an accident caused by a freaking ship
from sakaar
it's a car crash it's a car crash
it's a car crash who's in the ship what
message are they delivering what do we
what do they want with their boy bruce
banner and did hulk leave behind a baby
boy on
sakaar back in thor ragnarok holy [ __ ]
she hulk
holy shield
this is inside marvel it's new
rockstar's official she-hulk after show
i'm eric voss with me right now is mt
and jessica clemons welcome to you both
hi
dude i'm so excited to finally have this
episode like this i'm so good like it's
so funny very like deadpool vibes i love
breaking the fourth wall
i love this show my first impression of
the show is that the tone is so fun they
did such a good job like uh with the
humor with the meta breaking of the
fourth wall uh tatiana maslany is so
funny in this show like she's really
capturing the essence and the spirit of
everything that i would have wanted from
uh from jennifer walters especially with
her relationship with her cousin bruce
they have such this great chemistry this
kind of love-hate relationship and i
love that they aren't afraid to make her
unlikable sometimes that she's just kind
of like she's a bit arrogant as some
lawyers tend to be but you still are
rooting for her and like she's just
doing it like how pissed off she is that
her life as a lawyer it's gone awry the
arrogant moments come in the moments of
him then like sometimes natasha sings me
a lullaby and she's like why is this
woman grown woman singing you alone
that's what i'm like thank you thank you
for those justification moments of like
yeah it is weird
he's like i'm sensing judgment can we
not talk about this thank you she was
also the love of my life like if he said
that then we'd be like oh okay that's
fine this is like one of the first times
i think in the mcu that we've really
fully questioned the logic of how
hulking out goes down uh like i like how
he's like i don't really have a good
explanation for it like yes thank you
it's like the in the 2012 hulk film how
he's like spitting out he's like i spit
out a bullet so within this the fraction
of the time that when you try to shoot
yourself in a mouth that you'd be able
to spit out a bullet on the other end of
it that's how fast the transition takes
place
does the the inner lining of your of the
tissue inside your cranium hulk out
before the skin does it doesn't make
sense and i'm glad that this show is
actually finally having fun with it i'm
all about it i'm all about the hulk
science all right let's break down what
happens in this episode it opens with
jennifer walters deputy d.a practicing
her closing argument in a speech that i
love this it thematically mirrors a
spider-man with great power speech she
says those with the most power have the
most to answer for which just feels like
a hulk version of uh of the spider-man
with great power comes great
responsibility and i love the way that
they're doing the fourth wall breaking
to tell the audience that she already
has hulk powers but you know we
you figured that you want to know and
she has this great moment where she like
cuts away from her paralegal to go back
into her room so there's like within the
universe she has to like find a moment
away from the other people in her life
it's just interesting like deadpool
doesn't bother with that deadpool's just
like he's with dopinder in the cat in
the taxi cabin he's just like by the way
you know she doesn't she has to like
find these moments to sneak away from
people as if they can hear her which i
think is very very interesting on this
show i love that i think it follows i
like that deadpool does do it but i
think the writers of the show were like
let's lean more fleabag let's lean more
like this is a woman-led show before
it's like a superhero ledge show if that
makes sense and i think that's
fascinating i think by the time uh folks
are watching this on the channel a video
that i made yesterday will have already
come out that kind of digs into why
they're doing it this way and i i think
there's some very specific reasons why
they're doing it differently on this
show but we flash back to when jen got
her powers when she and her cousin bruce
were on this road trip and uh bruce
shows that the wrist device that we saw
in the shanghai post credit scene is an
inhibitor that he invented to keep
himself in human form while his arm
heals and bruce mentions interestingly
another genius in the family named ched
we'll talk about him a little later this
episode but jen debates whether steve
rogers was a virgin or not and uh then a
cecarian ship causes them to veer off
the road bruce bleeds into an open wound
on jen's arm and jen hulks out and
blacks out now uh we learned from an
interview with uh various interviews
with jessica gao and cat coiro that
originally this origin story was going
to be in episode 8 of the series but
they figured when they were like in
post-production that they needed to
restructure it because a lot of fans
might feel like we need this origin
story and it would have been hard for a
lot of viewers to watch this without
knowing really how this all started so
that's why you may notice on a lot of
these flashback sequences the vfx are
are unfinished or they found clever ways
to cut around it so you don't actually
see much of she-hulk's initial
transformations occurring on screen
because they just really ran out of time
when they decided to restructure it that
way i would have questions why would you
put that in episode eight why not just
decide a nine episode series
yeah in a nine episode series
i'm sorry i'd be a little irritated too
yeah yeah like especially if it's this
completely new hulk that like you have
no idea like a lot of people have no
idea where she came from so it's like uh
they need that origin like pretty early
right right especially the way the
origin unfolds it's not like a
monumentous thing it's just kind of like
his inhibitor thing glitches out and
that happens to be the moment he's
bleeding into her open wound and that
they're cousins so that causes her to
process gamer radiation the way he does
yeah it's not like a big surprise like
thematic shift it's just kind of like a
pretty straightforward explanation so
yeah i think it's smart that they put
this in episode one but it does deprive
us of the spectacle of enjoying how cool
she hulk looks when she is in her whole
form um they have to kind of cut around
it ultimately i think they pulled it off
i do think they stuck the landing at the
end of the day i was not bothered at all
by the vfx in this um you know your
mileage may vary i'm just the type of
person who watches this stuff that like
it's all fantasy you know yeah i'm just
trying to have fun really
we get this moment where it almost feels
like a terminator movie a little bit she
wanders into this bar where uh instead
of like immediately roughing up the bar
there's just this wonderful group of
women in the bathroom who helped clean
her up right oh i love them
[Music]
and it's so i'm so glad they chose that
moment because i have been
drunk in many a bars and sometimes the
women in the restroom are really mean to
me but no there's more often than not
it's always a group of women that are so
helpful and supportive and just want to
make a tick tock with you so i love that
we got this group of women
drunk lady let's make a tick tock
together i'm doing the dance like i
don't know i don't know
so she goes outside and some dudes are
bothering her what i'm just trying to be
nice whatever and this is the moment i
was talking about such a brief
two-second hulk out really uh and before
we even know what goes on like i had to
re-watch this a few times to realize
what exactly had happened hulk tackles
her in that moment but it's all such a
green blur um but again i in a video
that's going to come out on friday i'm
going to go through like the the i'm
going to just try to assess the vfx to
see like some moments where they try to
do some practical stuff um but uh just
so everyone knows jess is going to be
doing the easter egg breakdown that
should be coming out later today on the
channel so all the easter egg analysis
that jess is going to be handling that
for us for this season she-hulk so keep
your eye out keep your eyes out for that
i think she's going to be amazing
it's fun i found a lot of weird things
and i go in a lot of details
so bruce relocates her to its beach lab
in mexico this is built by tony stark
this is apparently where bruce spent the
blip this was the gamma lab where he
integrated his mind with hulk's body and
bruce explains that he and jin share a
rare set of genetic factors that allow
them to synthesize gamma radiation
becoming hulks he incinerates her blood
samples to prevent them from getting out
bruce experiments on jyn trying to
trigger her to hulk out but uh she she
does and she angrily smashes uh all
these razors and then bruce realizes
that jen interestingly does not have an
alter ego when she is in hulk form
unlike him he has another identity that
he has to wrestle with she doesn't it's
just all her all the time which i think
is very interesting uh we should
absolutely talk about that jen allows
bruce to train her and there's a really
fun easter egg here the shirt that bruce
wears has this indigenous uh symbol on
it's a thunderbird design and this is
actually a shirt that mark ruffalo
himself has in real life uh and ruffalo
is an outspoken advocate for indigenous
persons rights notably he stands with
the people standing rock um i wanted to
point this out here because i did like
circle that in a thumbnail for a trailer
breakdown and uh i did not know the
actual story behind it despite that so i
just wanted to crack that here i just
think it's a really cool easter egg when
they can bring in stuff from the actors
actual real life and stuff they care
about and and bringing it in the show so
the two of them train they throw
boulders they leap they stop they
practice balancing uh hulk gets jealous
and pushes her off a cliff it's really
fun um
we find out that hulks can metabolize
alcohol faster but jen gets inpatient
tries to leave this leads to a brawl
between the cousins uh both in hulk
forum we get some amazing
thunderclapping action that's exciting
right how'd you guys feel seen the
thunderclap come back
it felt good on the inside eric
it felt good on the inside i loved it i
even make a joke in the breakdown where
i'm like even though she hulks feels
like a thunder applause because she's
just
that's right i'm going off
and i love it i love that that'll be me
when uh
when i see a leapfrog i'm gonna be like
yes okay never mind i'm not giving i'm
not giving you the time of day for this
but what i did like is the fact that
what took us so long to see him do it
she does it in like what point five
seconds from the time he does it so i'm
like it's just
furthering that like she-hulk genuinely
takes these things much quicker and
easier than pulp does and i just love it
i just love it that they gave it to her
immediately yeah it's i feel like the
the lack of resistance is a huge factor
there because like bruce had to fight
with hulk and like he doesn't really
have a lot of his own mental self when
hulk is being hulk a lot of the time so
like yeah man she's just like yeah i can
do this it's easy like this is what you
mean like what do you mean you get it
girl she's just like what do you mean i
can do this in my sleep i can do this
all the time and i love her for it i
love her for it so at the end of this
fight the bar that bruce and tony had
built together gets wrecked so the two
cousins rebuild it together uh and they
peacefully part ways and then we're back
to the present day the day of the trial
and jen is up against the firm of glk h
her future employer that we know from
trailer footage uh titania smashes into
the courtroom uh who seems to be a a
major antagonist of the series though it
sounds like from interviews we may not
really get to know her a whole lot until
later in the season um jen decides to
hulk out gives titania the business
before returning to her closing argument
and then we get this post-credits scene
showing jen drinking with hulk in human
form and hulk finally confesses that cap
lost his virginity in 1943 to a woman on
the uso tour uh and jen declares before
we get to credits cap [ __ ]
i love it i love this spider-man cut to
black before we we get the full f-bomb
we're gonna dig into all these moments a
bit deeper let's start with this
sikharan ship okay first question who
was in the sicarion ship
yeah that is the question so bruce later
identifies as saw in the opening clip
the ship is a sakaran class a courier
craft probably trying to deliver a
message this ship has a similar ring
design to the grand master ship called
the commodore from thor ragnarok but it
is a very very different paint job the
commodore was a pleasure cruiser this is
a career craft meaning that in the world
of sakaar it's something like a ups
truck or federal express truck usps
truck something like that so what
message is this courier craft sending to
bruce banner well when bruce laughs last
left zakar this car and successfully
staged a revolution to overthrow the
grand master who who pathetically tried
to join their ranks uh there were
reports of a deleted scene from thor 11
thunder that would have shown gore the
god but you're meeting with and probably
killing the grand master but those were
removed meaning the grand master's fate
and mcu cannon remains unknown the grand
master could be summoning hulk back to
cicardo to defend the title against a
new warrior like hercules who we just
met or beta ray bill maybe adam warlock
who's coming up in guardians vol 3.
notice in bruce's beach house there is a
couple odds and ends that jess is going
to talk about the easter egg breakdown
but one of them is hulk's spartan style
gladiator helmet that he wore on sakar
this is important to point out because
it means that hulk must have either gone
back there at some point to retrieve it
because he did not have it with him when
they fled on the commodore or that
someone else brought it to him from
sakhar and knowing hulk's reputation
during this time as a as a gladiator
once a car the message could be that he
has a son
scar s-k-a-a-r
scar is hulk's son from the 2007 world
war hulk storyline in the 2009 scar son
of hulk storyline thor ragnarok
partially adapted the planet hull
corridor hulk events for the sakara
portions of that film but in the comics
hulk is actually sent off world by the
intelligentsia after he wrecks las vegas
and ends up on sakaar where he becomes
this warrior hero uh he hooks up with
kyra the old strong so cair produces
this cocoon uh that falls into a lake of
fire and scar emerges uh scar just kind
of ages super fast like initially he's a
kid but like a year later he's like
close to a grown adult he runs into
everybody he like faces silver surfer
and galactus then he gets exiled to
earth he fights among many people
juggernaut and then later doom he
actually joins norman osborn's dark
avengers to fight the new avengers but
he was actually steve rogers double
agent uh so this series may reveal that
hulk has a son on sakar but i just given
this series structure and focus as a
she-hulk series i don't think they're
gonna they would reveal that until maybe
the end of the series maybe as a
post-credits scene to the whole series
this could be something that gets
explored further in a world war hulk
movie or maybe in kang dynasty something
like that um i just think it's
interesting that bruce recognizes the
ship as a sakara in class a courier
craft because during his years on sakara
bruce was a buried consciousness within
hulk he had no memory of what was going
on in the outside yeah so he didn't have
much time on that planet in human form
to learn about sakharan's spacecraft in
the fleet he fled for asgard pretty
quickly this suggests to us that
sometimes during the blip in addition to
working the gamma lab to fuse his mind
and body perhaps sometime after end game
while his arm was healing and you know
we know he got to know captain marvel
during this time bruce had some
additional experience with
extraterrestrial civilizations like the
sicarians the cree the squirrels the
zandarians maybe and seeing the ship
might not have surprised bruce in that
moment like he could have said oh just
slow to a halt you don't need to steer
off the road jen i think he might
suspect what this message is already
about and he's not disclosing it jen for
whatever reason so i think scar as a son
is a very interesting possibility i
wonder though that this might shed light
on whatever's going on in the cosmic
front of the mcu right now maybe this
intergalactic war between the cree and
the squirrels that we'll see more of in
the marvels maybe whatever's going on
with adam warlock and the high
evolutionary in guardians vol 3 maybe a
looming threat like galactus i want to
know what you two think i uh really we
talked about it on the break room and i
talked about briefly also in the
breakdown but i love the idea of scar
coming in again i like i agree with you
i think it's way too heavy to be adding
that storyline so heavily into she-hulk
when she-hulk is about she-hulk we have
so many other things coming on already i
do think and believe that he went to
sakaar
again
after thor ragnarok because how did he
get that helmet there was a lot of stuff
that is in the show where i was like
these could all be zakarian things that
he went back and got in sakaar because i
don't believe he got it when he was
mentally just hulk he had to have been
smart hulk at this time i've been
conscious of what he was doing so i
think he does go back i just don't think
it's a letter about his son being born
yet but maybe them they have been trying
to reach him about his extended warranty
no about uh just coming back to just do
work to figure out civilization there
because i love in planet hulk that he
basically figures out like his his blood
can grow grass he is much needed there
he's very smart and this smart hulk can
maybe further them just like
intellectually and technologically so i
think they just want him back all the
time and he's like well i live on earth
so i think eventually maybe in phase six
we'll get into the story live and him
falling in love and having a child maybe
there's someone there right now that
he's starting that with but i don't
think it's about his child yet
that's me that is where i'm at but no i
really do think that scar it's a little
bit too early for scar and um but like
for me like knowing how thor ragnarok
went and how bruce basically transformed
from the hulk into bruce um like out of
nowhere
the grandmaster has no idea where the
hulk went like from his perspective the
hulk just disappeared he's like where
did he go like i lost thor
and i don't know where the hulk went so
i think the grand master's like let me
try to search for this uh gamma
signature to see if i can find this
weird big gamma signature somewhere and
then you found the hulk yeah is there no
way that this courier is just a subpoena
to come back and like go to court
because that was what i pitched in the
breakdown i was like this might just be
him getting subpoena to come back to
sakaar and that's why maybe in like the
ninth or eighth episode uh jennifer
walters can go to cicar because in the
comics she studies universal law and is
like
being the face for a bunch of people
universally so why doesn't she just go
to sakaar and fight for her brother or
cousin ontakar when he's being
subpoenaed for stealing and breaking a
bunch of [ __ ] on his way out
i think that's an it's a fascinating
theory maybe the fact that it's sakarin
is just the fact like this is just the
person who is uh delivering you know the
the subpoena you know it's just a
courier craft it's not doesn't mean it's
from sakaar it could be anybody in the
cosmos who's trying to summon bruce
right now and like so what if it's like
a matter of we know who's being judged
right now in the mc pretty much
everybody right and we have irishman the
judge who's judging the eternals on
whether or not earth is worth saving
maybe he's being summoned as a witness
on behalf of earth in cersei's trial and
that's where you have eros and pip
taking the other half of the eternals to
go like uh to lobby on behalf of of of
earth of all of earth in front of
airship the judge or whoever else may be
the higher maybe it's the living
tribunal right when the living tribunal
exists in the mcu uh in some physical
form based off of those statues in the
chamber and thor love and thunder so
maybe there's like some massive trial
that's happening in the mcu and then
basically uh hulk has a jury summons
i love that
i really dig that i really dig that a
lot well technically right now is he the
only
of
is he the only avenger right now this
takes place after like right after
shanghai where is uh doctor strange
uh he's still around
or he's got a third eye he's hanging out
with clea in the well i feel like once
he goes into the dark dimension he's
they're like okay we can't reach him
is bruce banner the only one on earth
right now i guess hawkeye is still there
uh well you have yeah you have captain
america sam wilson's hanging out
hawkeyes around uh
old man cap is on the moon we think we
don't really know
white vision is somewhere you know
don't even worry about that guy don't
worry about that guys
peter parker peter parker no one knows
who peter parker is i guess that's true
yeah right i think that spell applies to
everyone off world too whoever might
have known including like the guardians
and other sikarians and stuff
would that be right yeah with that being
questioned i was more so like that would
make sense that bruce would be the the
point of the point of contact
you know what's interesting is like the
the zakarians being the ones who serve
the paperwork sakarans have been called
paper people in the mcu right so they
might be the ones who are the couriers
in this case i'm reading into it i think
but
look here maybe yeah i i definitely feel
like this is uh because we know that the
grandmaster is one of the elders of the
universe and we know that each other in
the universe is obsessed beyond anything
with their particular hobby so like much
like we saw the collector being so
obsessed with collecting people i think
this is probably just the grand master
just being like hey you left and you
gotta fight for me no one leaves ever
i'm gonna get four too don't worry about
it um him and his new daughter they're
gonna fight for me um like so i think
that like they're just forever hunted by
the grand master for the rest of time
yeah i think it's uh
i think it is gonna be tied in either
with some kind of legal trouble or or
something that's happening in sakaar um
just because like putting a hulk in
something is a lot of vfx budget and i
don't think that we'll we'll just see
them pop up in guardians volume three or
the marbles they're gonna want to spend
that money
all right well we have so many more
questions coming out of this episode but
first we want to thank helix sleep for
sponsoring us sleep is important to us
here at new rockstars we trust helix to
protect our sleep with the best
mattresses in the world i have a helix
mattress as does empty and recently
producer zach and producer john also got
helix mattresses helix sleep has a quiz
it takes just two minutes to complete it
matches your body type and your sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you everybody's unique and helix knows
that so they have several different
mattress models to choose from they have
soft medium and firm mattresses mattress
is great for cooling you down if you
sleep hot matches is great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains even a helix plus mattress for
plus size sleepers producer zach took
the helix quiz and was matched with a
midnight lux mattress because he's a
side sleeper that needed a softer
mattress and now he doesn't wake up with
a sore shoulder or neck like he did with
the other mattresses that he's had helix
was awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2021 by gq and wired
magazine so just go to helixsleep.com
inside marvel take their two minutes
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com inside
marvel all right
i wanted to ask both of you
why do you think jen does not have an
alter ego when she is in hulk form other
than the fact that's just how it is in
the comics could there be some
in-universe reason in the in the movies
and films
well okay so
scar scar is also conscious gar is like
himself but scar is also himself he is
no he doesn't change between being a
human and whatever he is just
the offspring of hulk and then we have
uh abomination who is still conscious of
himself when he's abomination right yeah
at least we're especially we're seeing
that in the trailers and stuff of here
it's like he's changing she's like
change back down and he's like okay so
we get those i do think that this was
just maybe honestly affects just bruce
banner because i feel like every time
bruce banner's blood gets to someone
else or someone as offspring gets it
they are still conscious of who they are
maybe this situation only affects bruce
banner which could make sense because
bruce was also
self-diagnosing himself doing everything
himself whereas everyone else has been
affected like by him um if that makes
sense so i which it sucks i know it's
not the mathematical answer it's just
genuinely every other version of hulk
has the consciousness still themselves
or most of them do that i think that no
i think you're right on the money there
i think that like his blood or i think
the manner of which you become
irradiated with with gamma
is very much a factor here um in
particular because like in the
incredible hulk film with edward norton
um when it first starts off we they
that's when they show his origin like
with flashes and we see that like he
gets a direct shot of gamma directly
into his forehead and like it's a crazy
amount of gamma that only his blood
could um absorb because of a special
primer that um betty ross made that that
she injected into his bloodstream so i
think that it's the manner through which
the gamma is introduced to your body
because he got a [ __ ] ton of gamma and i
think that the hulk personality could
have been within that gamma radiation
and went directly into his brain that's
when that personality was introduced and
then when um jen gets his blood um she
just gets a little a little bit of the
constant gamma concentration enough for
her to change but not have a whole
different personality that's just a
weird hunch that i have
that makes sense the brain one is really
affecting me because it's also like so
what happens to the leader does the
leader when he finally change like
have no conscious is just like freaking
insane because he just had the cut in
his head no i think i don't know like in
the in the comics with the leader like
he sort of like abandons his old self
completely he's like he doesn't go by
samuel stern he's like i'm the leader
because i'm the smartest dude so i don't
know if that's a new personality taking
over if that's him i don't know that's
just me rambling that's a dude
that's a different man different guy
different character he doesn't see
himself anymore
new man you guys are right that like
it's not that uh jen is the unique one
here i think bruce is a unique one here
uh that seems to make more sense to me
that he's the odd one out he is the
really the outlier uh and that like
there's the more normal way to go about
this is to be a hulk that can like
retain your identity and not have this
separate uh personality i mean i don't
know i'm not gonna dig into like any
kind of diagnosis uh as if we're back to
moonlight i was gonna
yes
yes i but i was gonna agree with you
with that would make it also adds to
like incredible hulk and this hulk uh
that are doing yoga and uh engaging in
uh dialectical behavioral therapy
because it's like dealing with yourself
and personality disorder and that's why
it works for those people but it
probably wouldn't work in which it shows
that much on jen because jen's like i'm
i'm still myself i'm conscious of who i
am i'm not fighting someone inside
myself so
not to get too deep in the medical
diagnosis but i'm just saying those are
two other features that would make sense
why it works only on bruce banner and
not on jennifer walters or anyone else i
i think that there's also an
interpretation here that maybe
jen's alter ego is us it's the people on
the other side of the fourth wall so
when she's talking to us we are the
other
identity that she that she's sharing her
consciousness with that's like in a way
she's kind of wrestling with us i really
love that that is such a fun idea i hope
that's the case honestly yeah yeah i
don't know if they'll ever give us like
an in-universe answer as to why she's
able to break the fourth wall but i
think that's so interesting that only
she and deadpool and to a certain extent
wanda maximoff could do that because
juana maximoff within the west view hex
was able to do it but that was all like
part of agatha's spell but also
madness when she took over the 838 body
she looked directly into the camera and
i think that was meant to be a little
moment where she's breaking the reality
i i really hope they make it an actual
situation rather than like oh this is
just fits the theme for television
tropes and stuff
i would love it to be a reason like
she's a mutant or something weird i mean
i'll i'll accept it if it's just a
fleabag thing uh but i mean my favorite
moment of flea because when andrew scott
looks at the camera too yeah he's like
yeah
i talk about it when i break down i'm
like
in the breakdown i was like hopefully
that we like another loved one of hers
maybe the true one that she loves maybe
it'd be pug or whoever that notice that
came or two that shows that that's the
true love that's the that's the love
that's the flea bag way okay i'm sorry i
i honestly hope they reveal that she's
talking to the watcher or she's like she
can sense the watcher what if the
watcher is like
the watcher's like go girl you go
just eating popcorn like
the watcher loves this show the watcher
absolutely loves it
all right let's talk about this cousin
ched did i hear him right cousin chad
yeah
who is this person
i think i think uh
because i also theorize this on my
breakdown i think cousin shed
is supposed to be
related to the okay so in the comics her
family she has on the dad's side she has
an aunt named cassandra pike who is
literally an evil person she's a she's a
biologist and got a nobel p prize for it
but she also has a son that she turns
into a giant monster to kill jennifer
walters and her dad so i think ched is
that person who he's like yeah chad's
also the genius in the family because
he's related to the genius of the family
that is a biologist and he might be
smite by proxy i'm their entire family's
smart what am i talking about everyone
in their family is very smart they're
all
very intelligent people so i think he is
a smart person related to cassandra pike
in the comics i like that i like it i
love it i love that connection i i
really hope that there's something there
with that um with that comic book
connection because i would love to see a
monster chad um just fighting
why not jessica gao they did say i know
this because we do the break room and we
break down news all the time they did
say in an interview how this is gonna be
like we're getting really into their
family and then we're going to get more
hulk than ever was before they said like
we're going to get more hulk i don't
know about that but we are going to get
more family and i because one of the
courtroom illustrations is our entire
family out at dinner and the credits i
was like oh this is an entire photo of
her family we're definitely going to get
into their like
dynamic so maybe we will get a monster
shed
do you think that like because like we
know that the multiverse is the thing
and like the the the first incredible
hulk film with eric bana like and he his
dad was the absorbing man do you think
that in the mcu that could be the case
here
i would love that
that'd be good
i would love that also follow-up we're
not eric bana's 2003 incredible whole
doesn't connect like edward norton's
right in the mcu they don't acknowledge
it no no they're not they seem very
separate
like doesn't the eric bana hulk film and
with him in mexico or south america or
something like that and then so that's
kind of where ed norton yeah begins in
brazil it's sort of fun that's so loose
yeah
ages ago but they could take pieces like
that out of it and put it in here
because that was that's fun that's
amazing yeah uh you want to know some uh
how time is freaking crazy the
difference in the amount of time between
the eric banner and lee hulk in the 2008
hulk is less than the amount of time
between uh a doctor strange movies
in the mcu between doctor strange versus
manus yeah doctor strange multiverse of
madness there were six years between
those movies and then uh there's only
five years between two uh non-canonical
that is bananas the thing is
the bananas part is the doctor strange
one for me i'm like that was too long
you know he's 100 right because dr
strange's one came out in like what
2015-16
2016. but the difference is in between
those we got doctor strange yeah we got
three different movies he was an
infinity war and gay men and no way home
so it's like we got our daily dose of
the doctor um but uh i just find that
interesting uh yeah like i mean if you
go back between like uh you know even
toby maguire's last spider-man movie in
the first uh andrew garfield spider-man
movie or the last andrew garfield movie
and the first appearance of that was a
long time
yeah not that much time compared to like
gaps of time between us seeing
characters in the mcu i think this is
how entertainment just changed because i
remember back in the early 2000s we were
quick to change things up we were like
oh nope we're going to do a new one and
we're going to change the person like we
were quick to do it now it's a lot
harder it takes more time
yes what we did with incredible
yeah oh for sure i mean all the
characters in the mcu the amount of like
uh continuity and consistency between
these movies is really an anomaly when
you look at like the vast majority of
superhero fiction over the past 50 and
60 years 100 like people would be recast
all the time like that's kind of the
name of the game all the time yeah
that's why chris evans is like three
different characters
all right i want to end with this
question uh that the question the
question that this whole episode asks
cap's virginity hoodie loses virginity
to i'm honestly leaning towards the fan
girl played by laura haddock who plays
one [ __ ]
just because they had that moment in the
first cap film
yes like they they look at each other i
don't think it's one of those uso
dancers i think it's her i think you
know i think i don't think steve rogers
steve rogers would not have one hooked
up with one of the uso dancers he's too
polite he didn't want to start any drama
with the other uso dancers who he did
hook up with so this is a girl who comes
in you know she he knows he's gonna be
leaving the city the next day this is uh
i think it's gotta be her
thank you
thank you me and brandon are fighting in
the office about it because he thinks
it's uh
uh game of thrones uh marjorie oh
natalie dormir privately
yes but i don't think first off is the
uso tour and also yeah uh peggy was you
didn't yeah
until london until the ssr office in
london which was after the tour yes and
then someone also uh mentions that it
might be because i went back to watch it
just to be like who could it be right
and someone was like oh it might have
been the uso dancer that was peeking
through the curtain that's what i just
looked at her to the she gave me some
day
not as much as meredith quill not as
much as meredith quill dude she straight
up stop that was like literally johnny
cash elvis presley lying like can i get
your autograph like star-studded i'm
gonna have sex with you tonight and so
that's what i was like 100 it's this
woman who is not actually meredith quill
and like in a spider-man uh homecoming
we know that the dude from the howling
commandos they recast him as his
principal and like they has a direct
familiar connection so like
in the mcu you could use the same faces
for ancestors i guess so that's right
it's possible it's possible that steve
rogers could be the great grandpappy
i hate it and i refuse to believe it
but i love it but thank you vos for
making me feel less crazy because
everyone here in the office was like
jessica you're wrong it's not her and i
was like i mean she's got to be i mean
kevin feige said in an or not he didn't
say it but uh i believe jessica gao
cited kevin feige in an interview saying
according to you there is a canonical
answer to this question like feige knows
an answer and if you can imagine if
you're kevin feige looking back at that
first cap film is he just gonna pick
some random dancer no he's gonna pick
this this wonderful little moment with
this actor who later came back in the
mcu a few times like not to be a
horrible person but like and this isn't
horrible what i'm about to say if it was
a uso dancer don't you think they would
have maybe started a relationship off
that because they were dancing all
across the country every time together
you don't think they would have
continually hooked up no i mean maybe
they were [ __ ] all across the country
together too and they just didn't go
into it and they did it's cool and
you're you're going against our theory
boss there's a whole separate montage of
like in philadelphia cleveland
just just smashed beds in hotel rooms
across the usa
buy your government bonds to help pay
for the damage i did in the hotel room
last night
yeah the money is to fight the nazis and
protect the hilton suites
and protect the hilton
but like i think like because like you
know like law said like there is a
canonical answer to this i think that
they might be setting up a cap
like son grandson or something like a
cat family for future mcu um
installments i think that's a little bit
weird that possibility here we got to
get something like that or even like uh
the actual history channel documentary
of captain america that she references i
need one of those two to come through i
will have gone into this in my social so
everyone please follow me at eavos
um and uh be sure to follow jessica at
lulu underscore limits follow empty and
mastertainment that's it for this
episode of inside marvel so again jess
is gonna be handling the easter egg
breakdown this episode keep your eyes
peeled for that that's coming later
today we're but we're gonna have lots of
uh she-hulk related content on the
channel coming this weekend and uh yeah
if you're interested in other stuff that
new rockstars might cover uh i'm gonna
be doing breakdowns of house of the
dragon on hbo that's right i'm going
back to my roots covering game of
thrones content that's gonna be exciting
but be sure to subscribe to inside
marvel wherever your podcast subscribe
to new rockstars here on youtube we
thank you all for watching and we'll see
you next week bye-bye everybody thank
you guys
you